Micro tin what are the most useless
things you have memorized for me it's
old phone numbers like I still remember
the home phone numbers of my friends
growing up because I used to call them
from home so many times I still remember
like my friends who were among the first
to get mobile phones I still have a lot
of those numbers memorized and at this
point it's totally an unnecessary I
couldn't even tell you for almost anyone
that I'm regularly in touch with I
couldn't even tell you what area code
their phones are in you just don't need
to know their phone numbers and it at
some point could become a problem if if
you need to call someone from a payphone
to the extent that they even exist
because there's a power outage and your
mobile phone is no battery I'd be
completely screwed I mean maybe I'd be
able to find the info if it's synced to
my Google I I don't even know but it
would be bad I think there are a few
phone numbers you should memorize like
if you know you're living with a
roommate you may want to know they're
short or you know significant other my
parents parents and you want that
because if you're stuck out in the
middle of nowhere somewhere and you got
to contact someone yeah you got to know
that the other thing that I have
memorized that it serves absolutely no
purpose whatsoever are just like old
sports results like the game by game
series of like really important series
that I remember having watched like oh
well yeah the Celtics took the first two
games but then they lost a little enough
to win that like just random sports
stuff that you just end up remembering
either because its iconic or it was sort
of connected with something important in
your life or sort of like the the tree
the tournament tree that the argentinian
men's national team took in an old World
Cup to ultimately make it to lose to
Germany in the final or just really
stuff like that the results of Game
three of the 1974 World Series sure I
mean I don't even I couldn't tell you
why that's relevant it was is that a
particular that you don't know you just
seem like you know that one that one I
have no idea what it was even in it in
70 I don't know oh you don't know okay
so is it for me most of the things that
I find pointless to memorize at this
point are the types of things that have
become obsolete to know because of your
phone right okay it's really the phone
that has made a lot of types of
memorization totally obsolete I know the
number pi/2 like the 30th digit or
really and you know even if you are a
mathematician you
really need to know that many numbers
right I mean you could just look it up
or find it on your calculator pretty
easily this gets to a complaint that I'm
hearing more and more from both math
students and teachers which is why do
you really need to know so many of the
formulas that you used to need to know
for math class now before you could say
well there are circumstances were in the
real world these formulas would be
useful sometimes that's true sometimes
it's not right I mean the formula for
the formula whatever form it formula for
the area of a circle or whatever like
yeah okay there are actually times if
you want to calculate whether it makes
sense to get the large pizza that's a
useful tool to have but do you really
need to even memorize the formula no
that's an easy one right it's PI R
squared I think but you can easily look
up the formula so I actually do think
that there are legitimate questions now
I still am interested and I I still
think that knowing that stuff is
valuable because having that type of
thinking capacity is a useful thing in
general even if you're not regularly
calculating the area of a circle but
there's a pretty good case to be made
that operationally humans don't really
need to know a lot of that stuff because
you could just Google with the formula
right I mean the 21st century and what's
more important is being able to apply
the information rather than just to
memorize it because you could find that
stuff anywhere yeah exactly so I don't
always remember offhand okay how do I
I don't know quadratic equations or like
basic calculus I don't remember it but I
remember enough of the concepts that if
I were to find a formula I would know
how to use it right what about the
Pledge of Allegiance yeah did you grow
up with the pledge of allegiance oh
every single day but then again if you
ask me to just recite it now I'm not
sure if I would get through it I may
mess it up a little bit I pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation yeah and
then we get into the god stuff just a
new phenomenon through adding the god
stuff it was at it in the 50s yeah yeah
I actually remember that in elementary
school we had the the
pledge of allegiance but in in Middle
School in high school we didn't and I
don't know if there was a policy change
in Northampton Massachusetts schools at
that time but I don't remember ever
doing the Pledge of Allegiance in middle
or high school well you wouldn't in then
you were in a more conservative place
which is why you probably had it
throughout I was in a more American
place well that's how some people would
absolutely say yeah pointless I don't
know why I have it somewhat memorized
don't need it we'll probably never need
it again